i have seen on this podcast and just in
my day-to-day life
and that is the victim mindset and
victim mentality of modern women
so um the example i use of this is
something that's happened a couple times
in this podcast i've had men and women
both go viral on this podcast for the
wrong reasons okay
people come on the show and they'll wild
out
and what happens is the men i never hear
from they just kind of take the l and
move on
but the women will come to me and start
blaming me for their bad behavior on the
podcast and for going viral for the
wrong reasons
why do men take accountability for their
actions where women always seem to point
the finger i'd like to hear from the men
first
uh i guess you gotta find something but
i think
that there is from a young age as a boy
man
you're somewhat
held accountable from from then you know
so if you do something wrong especially
i'm nigerian so if you did something
wrong you're hearing from your dad when
he comes home you kind of think so you
know you you're told very early on your
consequences your actions have
consequences and so you need to
make sure that you don't do the wrong
things in order to not have those
consequences but a lot of times
i do think certain cultures don't have
that same energy when it comes to women
and that might be why
okay
yeah i just think
self-awareness and i feel like as a man
you're forced to have that you know i
mean from early days when you're in the
playground you know i'm saying if you're
fat you're the goalkeeper
but it just is what it is you know i'm
saying like you get picked last if
you're not the guy no one complains like
everyone kind of knows
like there's always there's an
accountability there's a hierarchy
amongst men like we just know from early
like where we kind of fit in in it like
we live in a world where
we get shown and told where we are all
the time and what what we are in it and
i just feel like for women there isn't
really that but i think their friends
just lie to them too much
leading on from that as well i think
it's self-awareness
if you're a man and you're short fat and
you're broke the world will tell you as
soon as you enter the dating marketplace
where you enter the world on what your
status is whereas a woman if you're if
you're overweight you'll probably have a
body body positivity group say that it's
the right way to be
so i think there's a lot of ways to
mummy cuddle women where there is men
aren't afforded that luxury
well to emulate what the manum said um
yeah men are forced to have to live in
in reality from young
girls growing up are just never told no
so they grew up with this idea that you
know the world kind of revolves around
them so
that's why i mentioned that you know men
have to create their value for our life
our women are are given their value so
with that you're afforded two different
mentalities as you're growing up and
going through life and
that allows women to
to operate from this facade of what the
reality shows so when anything goes
against that that kind of
cognitive dissonance there's a there's a
comparativeness to was that
so um question for the women
is is it just me is this just something
that i see where women don't take as
much accountability as men do
or have you seen that in real life like
do you agree do you disagree
um you can start okay i kind of
partially agree but at the same time
there was uh something that the last guy
said that just triggered something in me
like that that's just not true like i
think women do take accountability and
they are shaped
from young as well the levels of
accountability are very different and i
definitely agree
um the fantasy spin
i think is very feminine and they're
kind of like i'm gonna uh i'm gonna
reshape reality i think that is a
feminine trait but that doesn't mean
that both sexes don't have an issue with
accountability i absolutely think that
there is an issue with accountability in
society for all sexes at this moment
where do you see that men don't take
accountability
i think men don't take accountability
for
the
this status and um
actual kind of weight that they have put
on themselves and they complain about it
like it's women that have kind of put
this weight on their shoulders and how
they should shape their reality is like
because of women and and women don't
have that same pressure i think they've
done that to themselves can i have a
specific example i'm just i don't
understand what you're talking about
even just being like okay so i
the role of being the breadwinner or the
one that has to provide everything i
think that is men that have put that on
themselves i don't think that has
anything to do with women you don't
think you don't think that has anything
to do with women when women want a guy
that makes um at least 30 percent more
than them
no i i don't think there are that many
women that think that like that no no
it's if you survey women and ask them
they want a man that makes at least 30
percent more than that
and if and if a woman one of the number
one indicators of divorce is if a woman
out earns the man this is the difference
would that not come from men 100 what
would they not be the ones that are not
comfortable no no because because the
women initiate divorce so women leave is
70 to 80 no no 70 to 80 of the time
women leave and 90 if they're college
educated so the higher up a woman goes
in terms of income and status the more
likely she leaves okay now you're saying
she's leaving because she's earning more
and no i'm saying that she may be like
i'm not satisfied in this relationship
because
he has an issue with me earning more and
i don't want to stay in this dynamic so
from from what i've seen in the guys you
can maybe correct like you can tell me
what you've seen because you guys you
know you i i see the girls
i i found when girls move up in in
making money they're around more men
that make more money than them so i
think
on some level they kind of wish they
were with the men they were working with
rather than their husbands
so they kind of see what they're not
getting and then they they leave i i i
can see that in some circumstances but i
actually think the troubles in a house
when a woman is earning more
isn't necessarily about that dynamic
condition
this goes back to women's women's nature
so yeah we've all heard the term
hypergamy so women are married for
across up social hierarchies so
naturally women are programmed to always
get the best that they can get so at the
time when she got married her man that
might have been the best that she could
get at the time but as she elevates
herself past him then she's in a new tax
bracket with new men who are at a higher
level therefore that her pergamos nature
starts to kick in again and says i can
do better than what i currently have
neglecting that the man
in this situation is also contributing
to the dynamic of that relationship
there's contributing and is acting on it
so yes a man wouldn't divorce a woman
necessarily because she always wanted
him whereas
because she owns one but it may be hell
in that and this is the part that nobody
is going into so should she stay in a
house where it's hellish but this is the
thing to have hold on where are we going
because i just feel like the gold pulse
just got moved to like to where that is
it tends to be that if a man's earning
less than his wife he tends to be more
passive so what are the chances that he
would actually be
raising hell
and you also have to think about this
logically as well what if we're talking
about such a higher percentage figure of
70 percent of women leave but the more
high educated more money they make you
can't then argue like logically that
most of those situations have got the
man's given her health she's doing
better for herself why why is there not
surveys on actually the reasons why the
dominant reason for one is financial and
the second is infidelity yeah so women
leave for financial reasons
and women and men cheat at similar rates
it's like 23 the financial reasons that
are cited could that not literally be
that we had disharmony in our house
because i was earning more
but this is the thing though because you
know or what type financial reasons are
you talking about
the finances aren't enough so she has to
leave and find better because a lot of
times a lot of times women don't like to
have to do more work in terms of that
you know but what pay for bills but what
so the initial question was you said men
are held accountable and they put that
on themselves but what i'm saying is i
think the data indicates that men are
held accountable for this because if
your woman out earns you she's out the
door
so they they men have to deal with a
consequence
where where women where if a woman if a
woman gains a bunch of weight in a
marriage which to me is like similar to
the equivalent like usually the men
don't leave i don't know what they're
saying
what you'll be saying if a woman puts on
weight it's the same as if she earns
more no i'm saying like i think that the
equivalent of a woman a woman gave me
100 pounds is like a man losing a job
and refusing to work mm-hmm i would say
it's something
full of attraction instead of what what
we are what we're attracted to
okay because we women are attracted to
money money and status whereas men
we're visual creatures yeah okay so if
you take the visual aspect away from it
then
that's when they start treating with
cheating with the secretary and it gets
all happening i can kind of uh see where
that's going i i half kind of agree yeah
so what i'm saying is is women don't
seem to fit like i don't know a lot of
men in real time that are leaving their
woman because she gained weight